voilà péninou oui pour une histoire au
bac est un truc mais enfin on n'en est
pas là un anneau du jour n'ont pas là un
autre jour tu veux qu'on en parle
maintenant ils nous ont rejoints stomy
bugzy et pas s'ils sont avec leur
sélection toi t'as pas changé non merci
gravité roncquois c'est un fait regardez
moi ça c'est par playboy celle à 100
alors on va parler de plaintes wild west
met des petits mise à mal et frérot
chico tendrait à la poche chez nous
bon vous appelez nous c'est fini tout ça
est quoi qu'est ce qui se passe avec ni
nouvelle parce que c'est vrai que vous
m'appeliez ni nous c'est vrai que ça
vaut la peine ou wii pour les histoires
ont marqué un truc mais on en parle on
en parlera un anneau dur non pas là un
autre jour il faut qu'on en parle
maintenant moi que je suis parti il ya
quatre ans vous êtes parti aux états
unis
ouais ouais mais on s'en fout de sa
sortie de sa rencontre à république tu
étais en galère tu souffrais ont mangé
des merguez frites ont galéré
maintenant je reviens en france soit
kwasny nous séduit le cador
[Applaudissements]
je te rappelle qu'on avait fait un team
ensemble ouais c'est vrai qu'on a fait
un film que personne n'a vu way sortira
peut-être jamais eu un jour où il a
comme moi donc j'ai des extraits porter
attendait alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
m
bah moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monga barre
et à cause d'elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sandy wood roi si l'ambiance est folle
mais que ne manquerait il m'amène à
l'école
[Musique]